una vez más la crisis política atraviesa
a Perú no estamos hablando de El tercer
intento de moción de vacancia contra
Pedro Castillo varios presidentes en los
últimos años por qué cree usted que sea
Perú a esta situación que no es nueva
Vamos en un periodo más que complejo
justamente porque las elecciones desde
el año
2016 están marcadas por el
antifujimorismo y lo que tenemos
nosotros como una constante acá es que
realmente cuando se dio por ejemplo la
elección del año 2016 tuvimos nosotros
Un gobierno bastante débil en este caso
el presidente Pedro Pablo kuczynski hay
que recordar que el presidente kuczynski
termina renunciando no es vacado el
presidente luego de que renuncia es
reemplazado por Martín vizcarra quien a
su vez termina disolviendo parlamento
posteriormente termina siendo vacado hay
un gobierno breve de Manuel Merino de
Lama quien justamente por movilizaciones
ciudadanas termina renunciando y en
transición democrática el presidente
Francisco sagasti ASUME el liderazgo del
país hasta que se produce la elección
del 2021 elección en la cual como
manifestado nuevamente en una segunda
vuelta que tenemos acá cuando los
candidatos no superan el 50% de la
votación bueno colocan a una persona
como Pedro Castillo definitivamente pues
hoy día podemos calificarlo de golpista
felizmente acaba de ser vacado por el
congreso de la República también se ha
dado un pronunciamiento de las fuerzas
armadas como bien han señalado ustedes
en su cadena noticiosa de respaldo
constitucional todos los organismos
públicos peruanos también los poderosos
jurisdiccionales el tribunal
constitucional del poder judicial los
organismos constitucionalmente autónomos
la defensoría del pueblo entre otros se
han manifestado en el sentido de
respaldar la democracia el señor
Castillo se quedó solo y literalmente
ahora vamos a tener una etapa en la cual
vas a reemplazado por la primera
vicepresidenta que es inaloarte Es la
primera vez que el Perú va a tener una
dama de presidente lo cual Esperemos que
nos dé cierta tranquilidad y también por
si acaso se está hablando mucho de un
tema de adelanto de elecciones es muy
probable que en el Perú se vuelvan a
convocar elecciones para el nuevo
mandato de cinco años de autoridad
nacionales
Ahora qué pasa con la votación que
realiza un congreso que horas Antes
había sido disuelto por el propio
presidente qué legitimidad tenía el
congreso para llevar a cabo esta
votación
Es que lo que pasa es que la
Constitución prevé que cuando se rompan
constitucional surge o se puede dar el
derecho de insurgencia incluso nadie
está obligado a acatar lo que es un
gobierno de facto un gobierno
dictatorial contra constitucional o sea
es clarísimo que eso Por ejemplo es el
sentir que también ganes personas
fuerzas armadas
han expresa los organismos públicos la
población también en su conjunto porque
esta situación ha generado un rechazo
multitudinario entonces realmente creo
que lo que está haciendo el congreso que
nunca ha sido disuelto es un acto
legítimo de vacancia un presidente que
sí más bien ha roto la reconstitucional
Ahora sí sin ningún ningún ninguna duda
lo ha terminado de hacer y lo que
corresponde fue que el señor responda
ante las autoridades
cuéntenos como bueno como experto tanto
en abogacía como como analista político
a las 15 horas va a juramentar quien
ejercía como primera vicepresidenta de
Perú no asumirá la tarea bueno de ser la
presidenta del país Cuáles serán luego
los pasos a seguir habrá convocatoria a
elecciones que ocurrirá
lo que ocurre justamente es la necesidad
de que haya nuevas elecciones pero
Primero lo primero esta juramentación
Medina buluarte como presidenta
constitucional de la República va a
traer consigo la designación de ministro
de estado y era un Premier o peruano Y
eso va a generar de que haya una
necesidad de conversación entre lo que
viene a ser el gobierno nueve nuevo el
nuevo gobierno liberó por navoluarte y
el congreso y lo que se tiene que dar y
acabo con un tema de fondo es un
adelanto elecciones porque actualmente
como está la situación se necesita un
adelanto de elecciones dado de que es lo
que podría dar mayor calma de alguna
otra manera también el congreso tiene
algunos cuestionamientos Y en este
escenario es cuando corresponde
justamente que las autoridades que ahora
están conduciendo el país
evalúen la posibilidad de dar un paso al
costado nuevamente a la ciudadanía para
que se la nueva representación nacional
un nuevo congreso de la república Y un
nuevo ejecutivo pierde los cinco años
por si acaso para que lo sepan los
televidentes una situación parecida
experimentamos nosotros en el año dos
cuando justamente
Victoria anuncia la voluntad política de
él y de congreso que era mayoritaria de
renunciar o sea a su mandato por cinco
años de convocar elecciones y el
parcialmente no iba a volverse a
presentar porque justamente
cuestionamiento vino la razón de una
reelección o sea una doble reelección
estamos nosotros viviendo un periodo que
digamos complejo pero también hemos
vivido estas situaciones anteriormente
un autogolpe como el que se preprendió
de hoy día y que finalmente prosperado
lo tuvimos en el año 92 en el año 2000
como lo he mencionado tuvimos el
escenario del banco de elecciones y
ahora me parece que el orden
constitucional no se ha acre nuestro
país porque al no tomar partido nadie
por el señor Pedro Castillo
definitivamente este intentó la golpista
ha fracasado y lo que se va a dar ahora
es una transición democrática y el Perú
podemos decirlo con cierta tranquilidad
en medio de toda esta situación tan
compleja está transitando una crisis
nuevamente dentro de los parámetros
constitucionales y legales vigentes
ahora señor deseo usted me corregirá y
me dirá si esto es efectivamente así
porque hay trascendidos según los cuales
la policía estaría a cargo y tendría la
orden de detener a Pedro Castillo bajo
el argumento de haber roto el orden
institucional
es lo correcto en un estado de derecho
una persona que comete delitos y un
delito es justamente quebrantar el orden
constitucional tiene que ser retenida
malaria incluso y es una postura
personal
alguna país alguna embajada y darle
algún tipo de asilo porque este señor es
un golpista tiene que estar preso Y eso
es una opinión personal y lo que digo si
bien es una opinión personal lo digo
también cuando arreglo a la normatividad
vigente porque en un estado de derecho
una persona que comete este tipo de
delitos y hablamos de delitos no es un
perseguido político es un delincuente y
tiene que estar preso
entonces escenarios que se abren la
renuncia y la detención
esperemos que se dé Bueno más que la
renuncia a la vacancia señor castillo y
el tema de la detención esperemos que
prospere porque esta persona tiene que
responder con sus actos acá no estamos
hablando de un tema que tenga solamente
un Matiz político parece político pero
realmente este señor es un es una
persona que tiene que responder por
delitos por favorecer a su familia por
favorecer intereses personales actos de
corrupción que cada día tienen mayor
sustento es una persona que además
también ha logrado generar en el país un
serio problema de credibilidad en las
instituciones por toda una serie de
situaciones que se han producido y que
ustedes ya han venido detallando antes
de que tengamos este espacio de
entrevista entonces realmente esta
persona tiene que responder ante la
justicia porque los suyos más que un
tema político Ya pasa a ser un tema
judicial y tiene que responder ante la
justicia
ahora para aclarar un poco esto no
porque se estuvo mencionando un poco el
tema de la renuncia si ya está por fuera
del gobierno
Qué opciones le queda ante esta moción
de vacancia no le queda otra que
aceptarla y recurrir ya veremos A qué
instancias podría hacerlo o tiene
herramientas para seguir intentando
continuar en el poder no en lo que se
refiere a una vacancia ya no le
corresponde a él nada Tuvimos una
vacancia haciendo mucho tiempo de Martín
vizcarra en el acto tuvo que dejar el
ejercicio del poder y sea la transición
democrática que prevé justamente que
ante la vacancia del presidente el
primer o el segundo vicepresidente
asuman el mando en este caso hablamos de
la primera vicepresidenta Dina boluarte
porque quien era el segundo
vicepresidente es una persona que
terminó siendo excluida de las
elecciones el señor Vladimir cerrón
entonces realmente el orden por la
primera vicepresidenta de no estar ella
en digamos en condiciones o no aceptar
el cargo pasaría a quien es presidente
del Congreso porque ese es el orden
constitucional que establece
nuestro país nuestra legislación y
obviamente con la convocatoria de
elecciones en lo cual se tiene que
producir en una línea de tiempo de 270
días Entonces tenemos que evaluar este
tipo de escenarios pero realmente lo que
sí hay que dejar bien en claro es en el
Perú y en esto sí quiero ser bien claro
se intentó romper el orden
constitucional Pero ha fracasado para
alivio de todos nosotros